guess what time it is rossi favorite
it's time for pop quiz
okay
where is samantha cashman okay samantha
right over here come over
come on
samantha riding up in a gorgeous boot
and a purple flare that we're both
feeling i'm so excited i'm very excited
do you think good
and your last name is cash man yeah oh
you're gonna win all right
samantha you can get your ass down okay
if you answer these three questions
correctly about today's show you're
gonna win a special prize samantha are
you ready all right okay
what did ross gift me for make a gift
day
this is a macaroni and cheese frame
a macaroni and cheese picture frame
that's it
second question how did michael yuri's
parents meet my real mother and father
met on a blind date blind date binding
is right you were paying attention
what is the name of cal pen's new memoir
is out now
but you can't be serious
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow okay samantha you have won an
electric bike and scooter package from
go track
[Applause]
i can share it with my kids um really
quick maura lynn kara and kenny oh
but there's there's stuff for them
santa came early oh good thank you
[Applause]
and thank you everybody so much for
choosing to spend your time with us we
make this show for you so
take it with you
[Music]
you